projet était au faîte sur les personnes
noires pour jouer un rôle d'othello
africain on n'a pas besoin de se mettre
à la peinture noire sur le corps il y as
suffisamment des comédiens des
enterrements
ah oui d'accord mais est-ce que c'est
peut-être parce que ça coûte trop cher
de les embaucher
ou peut-être que le metteur en scène et
le producteur estime ou estimerait que
ils ne sont pas assez qualifiés n'ont
pas assez de talent pour leur seront
face que diégoune chioui ya beaucoup de
tort qu'ils ont dit je vous le dis oui à
beaucoup de temps qu'ils ont dit on et
pourquoi ils ont pas pris un comédien
noir voilà et c'est ici c'est qu'on
attendait mais de gens ont dit sur les
réseaux sociaux ça chez moi j'exerce est
alors jean les charges et une autre
question à poser mais quand omar sy a
joué arsène lupin oui y'avait pas
d'acteur blanc suffisamment talentueux
pour jouer arsène lupin ils seront
terminés je ne comprends pas non mais je
finis mon propos je sais je ne comprends
pas cette rage féroce qu'il y a de 2,2
des noirs et de la diversité de manière
générale à vouloir faire jouer des ddd
des personnages historiques blanc de
chez blanc par des noirs ou par des gens
de la diversité mais lorsque c'est le
cas inverse et bien là on hurle au loup
d'alcool désolé moi non non non non non
que moi pour moi c'est un acteur écoulée
nous sommes dans un pays libre
or et je vais vous dire quelque chose
oui on va continuer à se peindre en
blanc en bleu en rouge en or entre temps
d'organiser quelque chose
d'accord je me tiens je termine le rouge
tout droit que et on va continuer
effectivement à ceux déguisés en indiens
qu'on joue louvre en un message lui même
prend vahiné on comptait son put etc
pire selon m c'est à les y encourager je
peux pas finir ma frange de deux heures
moi compter les villes at il pas là on a
dit un truc la poutre voilà j'ai des
gestes simples simplement je dis ici
nous sommes dans un pays libre si
effectivement un signe de certaines
communautés trouve qu elles ne sont pas
respectées suffisamment alors que la
france est pourtant l'un des pays sinon
le pays où il ya le plus de tolérance au
monde
on est bien libre à ceux qui sont pas
contents qu'ils nous emmerdent avec leur
complexe et leurs délires d'aller se
faire cuire un oeuf et si le blanc de
l'oeuf vous gêne vous avez qu à
l'enlever alors moi juste pour le gars
et moi je pars du principe qu'à partir
du moment où on fait que certaines
personnes c'est qu'un souci et en suisse
israël met alors un choix en débat
toujours un journée avec la ville de
défense noire africaine n'est par contre
que en caucasien pu jouer le rôle d'un
africain et vice versa omar sy pour
jouer lupin ne s'est pas mis la peinture
sur le corail s'est pas mis d'accord
mais le 6 juin si je suis vous avez
parlé je me fais penser je suis le
raisonnement de cyril hanouna où il ya
effectivement des gens qui lorsqu'ils
ont vu arsène lupin joué par un noir ont
été vexés celle endroit là bas là mais
c'est leur droit
voilà ce que nous disons au fait il faut
comprendre que notre couleur de peau
n'est pas en déguisement en venant vous
voir ici
la seule chose que je ne pouvais pas
laisser chez moi oui c'est ma couleur de
peau agent peut laisser ma religion avec
vous je peux laisser mes orientations
sexuelles tout mais sauf ma couleur de
alors un goodie permettez nous reste de
belles je sais mais je suis une
révélation je finissais il faut
comprendre que ce bris mais se met à la
peinture sur le corps aujourd'hui en
france la négrophobie tu d'accord je
vais
attendez je finis oui je sais vous
n'arrêtez pas de finir je voudrais que
les gens en france aujourd'hui on peut
traiter des gens de sale [ __ ] de sale
noir sans le championnant allez j'en ai
c'est une saisie ces questions alisation
je vais vous poser la question est ce
que nous sommes là je vais vous ne vous
ai pas parlé de je vais vous poser son
bilan mais posez votre question